[Applause]
so
in a week where there was a lot of
things unfortunately to be depressed
about
um kovid coming back the fires
out here uh the capitol police story me
having to wear glasses
i must say the award for lowest violist
was the conservatives who went after
simone biles
this pissed me off in a way few i mean
let me read some of these right wing
charlie kirk i know who that is
i called her she's ashamed of the
country
the texas deputy attorney general aaron
rights national embarrassment some other
i never heard of but gets quoted
by people i have heard of
called her a quitter um piers morgan
returning to his more natural realm of
being a huge
dick said there's nothing heroic or
brave about
quitting buck sexton this feels
like the antithesis of what an elite
athlete
would do um oh no i'm sorry the athlete
credo would be
we've had him on the show buck you
seemed like a normal nice guy
but you know what unless you act like a
normal nice guy you're
you're in here in the division
i i mean i just i just want to reiterate
what i said
this is not a choice we ran this poor
girl
this amazing machine till it not
permanently
but temporarily just broke it yeah i
mean can you imagine the anxiety these
these armchair quarterbacks sitting
there do you know what it is
crumbs on their shirt looking at someone
who twists and flies in the air and ends
on a little strip
and it's like ah well boy where's your
mental toughness
my response to them is they can kiss my
overworked black woman ass
i was going to second that i guess i can
because you know i saw an article today
from
glamour magazine which really did was
fascinating to me
talking about what this young woman has
been through
in terms of overcoming sexual the sexual
scandal that occurred in gymnastics
having the kind of pressure on her
being the best gymnast that has ever
been in this field and she needs the
opportunity if she wants
to rest and they were discussing the
fact that historically culturally
black women have never had the
opportunity to rest
to say i've had enough i'm tired you
know we have
built this help build this country she
has done what she can
they could never i don't think she wants
to rest
i think she i don't think she wants she
needs to be mentally she just
you ca pushed her
to the ultimate limit she sucked it up
as long as she could can you imagine the
anxiety
i mean how do you even sleep and we know
now that when you don't sleep fully and
i mean fully
you're at way less than full capacity we
just
i know she her choice would always be to
personally what's so gross about
the the right wing back i mean everybody
saw this coming right
it's part of that ecosystem of
right-wing
baiting that sparks an angry counter
reaction among liberals
everybody starts screaming and fighting
and trying to cancel each other
and what they've what they've done is
politicized something that isn't
remotely political
you